everything everywhere all at once is as
dense of a movie as its title promises
and it all revolves around a literal
everything bagel here's all the stuff
you need to know about how well
everything plays out warning spoilers
ahead
in the multiverse there are an infinite
number of universes for every event that
has multiple possible outcomes either by
decision or random choice a new universe
is born one of these outcomes results in
the alpha verse or the first universe to
successfully make contact with the
others the alpha versus residents
developed the technology to map an
individual's life path the technology
allows them to project their
consciousness into their counterparts
bodies in other universes by doing this
they acquire the memories skills and
emotions of alternate versions of
themselves this is called quote verse
jumping the more different they are from
their alternate persona the weirder
verse jumping gets for instance for
evelyn to access the skills of an
alternate evelyn who became a martial
artist and film star she needs to
earnestly profess her love to a woman
who's trying to kill her
by the end of part one everything we've
learned that the omniversal being evelyn
supposed to defeat jo butupaki is the
alphaverse counterpart to her daughter
joy joby was created when evelyn's alpha
subjected joy's alpha to rigorous verse
jumping experiments in the words of
alpha weymouth splitting one's
consciousness between multiple alternate
versions of oneself is like putting a
crack in a clay part if it cracks too
many times it'll shatter beyond repair
in this case alpha joyous become unstuck
from her reality and gain the ability to
become any and all versions of joy as
well this gives her the reality bending
powers of a living looney tunes
character and the madness to match alpha
raymond recruits the worst reality of
evelyn and the multiverse to fight jobu
tupaki for a specific reason he believes
that a multitude of unfulfilled life
paths make her uniquely suited to
advanced adverse jumping every rejection
every disappointment has led you
most of the action of the film takes
place in the irs universe it's here
where the worst evelyn is told that she
must confront the world's destroying joe
butupaki alpha weymouth tells her that
her mission is to counterbalance jobu's
evil with good but his boss alpha gong
isn't as confident in her potential he
orders her to kill joy her own daughter
so that jobu will no longer be a threat
to this particular universe evelyn
refuses insisting there must be another
way to rid her daughter of jobu's
influence this leads alpha gong gong to
call for reinforcements and evelyn ends
up fighting jobu jobu's cultists and the
alpha versus resistance her only ally is
alpha weymouth who occasionally jumps
into irs raymond's body to help but is
eventually killed in his own universe by
jobu rather than hanker hopes on winning
the battle evelyn deliberately pushes
her mind beyond its shattering point
evelyn's multiversal overload marks the
end of part 1 and takes us into part two
everywhere evelyn's consciousness now
bounces between a number of universes
while it's easy to consider irs evelyn
is the only real evelyn that we're
following for the rest of the film but
that's not really the case from hero
announced there's just one evelyn
there's just one mind shared across an
increasing number of possible lives
until evelyn herself reaches omniversal
consciousness we see a fair sampling of
the universes that she's inhabiting for
ease of discussion let's label the most
important ones the spine of the story
happens in the irs universe this is
where alfa raymond recruits her into the
multiversal war the party universe is
what would have happened if alpha
weymouth had never shown up in the irs
universe in the movie star universe a
young evelyn becomes an international
movie star and martial artist and
finally the most unique the hot dog
fingers universe this is where all human
beings have big limp hot dogs for
fingers and evelyn and deirdre are a
couple
as an experiment jo butupaki has used
her power over reality to create and
quote everything bagel which turns out
to be an all-consuming black hole the
resistance of the alpha verse believes
that this is a doomsday weapon but
actually jobu is planning to use the
bagel to end her own life ultimately
jobu has been in search of someone who
can ascend to her plane of existence
understand what she's going through and
maybe talk her out of destroying herself
once evelyn becomes able to jump
effortlessly between all realities
alongside her daughter she takes to
jobu's nihilistic philosophy all too
well across the multiverse evelyn starts
acting out of cruel selfish impulse
hurting those around her because why not
if there's an infinite number of
universes in which every imaginable
outcome is happening simultaneously then
there's no meaning behind any of it
nothing matters but the bagel the circle
is a very important symbol in the movie
uh to me it's about reunification in
interviews dan quan and daniel scheinert
have equated the multiverse of their
film to the experience of modern life on
the internet people who have grown up in
the digital age have a totally different
sense of scale to their world than the
generations that came before them joy
slash jobu is a grown-up millennial
who's plugged into an overwhelming feed
of constant often contradictory
information she's measured her own value
impact and suffering against a sum total
of existence and can no longer bear it
after jobu shows evelyn the everything
bagel evelyn had a dead-eyed nihilistic
meltdown that spans multiple universes
she's seen the life she could have lived
if she'd never come to this alternate
reality so she no longer has any reason
not to act on her resentment for example
deirdre shows up to the laundromats
chinese new year party with a police
escort with the intention of
repossessing the property when evelyn
smashes the front window of the
laundromat with a baseball bat it's not
just an act of defiance against deirdre
but an expression of her loathing for
the laundromat and what it represents to
her across the multiverse evelyn stops
caring about the consequences of her
actions or their effect on others she
then shuts out all these universes to
live as a rock on an earth where life
never developed because that means she
won't have to think about any of it
throughout the entire film evelyn has
been cruel and dismissive towards
weymouth she sees raymond as naive and
weak willed while we see that evelyn
could have achieved great things without
him in her life we also see the positive
results of weymouth as well especially
when it comes to ayman's philosophy of
unconditional kindness throughout the
entire film and each time evelyn barely
notices for example when evelyn stays in
the forefront he defuses a conflict with
a dissatisfied customer at the
laundromat by dancing with him even when
he draws up divorced paperwork he does
it in the hope that they'll be able to
turn their marriage around before it's
too late it's only after evelyn has
totally given up on life that she
appreciates the power of raymond's
kindness in the irs universe he refuses
to give up on evelyn even after she
stabbed him all he wants is for everyone
to stop fighting so evelyn can help
their daughter evelyn has never reached
this level of understanding with the
women she married but now she can look
back on their life together and see the
beautiful parts of their relationship
more clearly the reveal that he's not
his squirrel yeah squirrel would just
like his like cuddly sweet innocent
version of himself
at around the same time that evelyn is
reassessing her relationship with
weymouth she's approached by deidre in
the party universe waymund assault
deidre of his and evelyn's pending
divorce deidre a divorcee herself
sympathizes with evelyn but evelyn knows
that deirdre isn't unlovable because in
one far-off universe she loves deirdre
and the two of them are built to life
together it's probably not a coincidence
that immediately after this reflection
on her relationship with deidre in the
hot dog fingers universe evelyn has an
epiphany about how she's been reacting
to her daughter's sexuality joy has been
dating her girlfriend becky for three
years but evelyn remains at best
begrudgingly tolerant of the
relationship evelyn even attempts to
blame joy's attraction to women on the
malevolent influence of jobu tupaki
portraying that evelyn has seen
homosexuality as an affliction rather
than a natural part of her daughter's
life at the start of the film evelyn
hurts joy by introducing becky to gong
gong as joy's good friend now after
accepting her own love for deidre evelyn
marches up to gong gong and corrects
herself
when joe butupaki summons the everything
bagel to the irs universe evelyn has
only a short amount of time to keep it
from destroying her apart from raymond
everyone present wants jobu to go
through with them with evelyn now an
omniversal being she could easily
destroy the entire army that stands
between her and her daughter but instead
she adopts raymond's strategy of
fighting with kindness when we first see
jobu take apart a trio of police
officers earlier in the film it's hard
to make total sense out of how her
powers work she's basically operating
under cartoon rules able to do anything
so long as it amuses her once evelyn
acquires the same power we gain a
slightly better understanding of it each
time she confronts an alpha verse
soldier she peers into the web of their
alternate lives and then uses that
knowledge to make changes to reality
when joby would make changes that were
destructive or deadly evelyn does
something that makes her opponents happy
granted these are still cartoon rules
but the tone of everything everywhere
all at once doesn't demand literal sense
what's important is that evelyn uses the
absurdity and chaos of the multiverse to
create joy rather than pain
even after fighting a dozen people to
prevent jobu from diving into the
everything bagel the divide between
evelyn and her daughter is not entirely
mended joy doesn't feel she can trust
that things will really get better with
her mother in the long run their
relationship is punctuated by intense
moments of drama that caused joy a great
deal of stress and pain and she still
thinks she'd be better off if they went
their separate ways in the party
universe joy plans to drive away from
the laundry mats and never look back joy
has a crushing fear of inadequacy she
doesn't just believe that she'll never
be enough for her mother she also feels
that she could never matter at all in a
final effort to calm that fear evelyn
confesses that yes the multiverse is
unfathomably large but out of the
limitless possibilities of existence
what she wants most is to be with her
daughter it doesn't matter that there
are other better versions of each of
them out there the lives they're living
right now are just as insignificant and
therefore just as important as any of
the others because we've traveled across
the multiverse we found each other yeah
that was one thing we discovered was
like at the end of the day we are
looking for each other
part three all at once is a brief
epilogue that takes place entirely in
the party universe evelyn is a changed
woman now more affectionate towards
weymouth more accepting of joy and becky
and sporting a more positive outlook on
life if a viewer is so inclined they
might argue that the entire adventure in
the multiverse has occurred only in
evelyn's head and that the party
universe is the only real universe in
the film as evelyn sits down with her
family for their makeup meeting with
deidre we discover that she is still
hearing voices from the other universes
in her head assuming that these voices
are real this suggests that evelyn still
exists in all other universes at once it
also suggests that she's made the choice
to remain present in this world rather
than obsess over the roads not taken
she's at peace with the life she's lived
the family she's built and the
possibilities that lay in her future not
just in her past check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]